Narrator: These are the Sharks.
They have achieved incredible
success as entrepreneurs
and investors
in multiple sectors.
They all came
from humble beginnings,
and are all self‐made.
The Sharks know what it takes
to build business empires
from nothing into billions.
Now they are investing
in entrepreneurs' dreams.
‐Butts are back.
‐The product sells itself.
We've done $15 million
in sales.
‐Wow!
‐What?!
‐$15 million?
I'd love to do a deal on this
with Mark and Lori.
Oh, just to beat the hell
out of Kevin.
Narrator: This is the art
of doing business.
I'm so valuable,
it's ridiculous.
Kevin,
would you excuse us?
This is "Shark Tank."
You're making a big mistake
if you don't do my deal.
Oh, help me, Lord.
Ooh!
I don't know
if we're here to negotiate.
[ Indistinct shouting ]
This is exciting.
‐I'm Shannon.
‐And I'm Regan.
Shannon: And we're
from San Diego, California.
Come on, James!
We're two busy moms
always on the go.
Regan: Shannon and I met at
our kids' preschool field trip.
After a long day
with 40 4‐year‐olds,
we were ready
for a glass of wine.
[ Both cheering ]
We dropped our kids off
with our husbands,
and we've been friends
ever since.
Regan and I both worked
in corporate America
for several years,
and it came
a point in our lives
where we just wanted
to do something different.
Every couple of weeks,
Regan and I would meet
for happy hour,
but once we started
talking about moving directions
in our careers,
our happy hours
turned into business meetings.
And we came up with an idea
that we loved.
So we decided to start
a business together.
Thank you.
I'll take this one.
Our product seems to be
flying off store shelves.
Retailers are starting
to get frustrated
that we can't keep up
with the demand for the product.
We're starting to get
bigger orders,
and we don't have
the inventory
or the money
to fulfill those orders.
You guys hungry?
It's not easy having
a family and a business.
There's a lot of sacrifices
that need to be made.
We're hoping an investment
from the Sharks
will help us
grow this business
into the success
that we know it can be.
♪♪
Hi,
I'm Regan Kelaher.
And I'm Shannon Zappala.
Our company is Goverre,
and we're here today
seeking $200,000
for a 13% stake in our business.
So we believe that everything
is better with wine.
‐Yes.
‐Wine at the park.
Wine on a picnic.
Wine at a pitch meeting
with investors.
But what we don't love
is pouring our nice wine
into plastic cups
and then it spilling
as soon as we set it down.
We knew there had to be
a better option,
and that is why
we invented Goverre.
Goverre is the only
portable wine glass
with a drink‐through lid.
Simply pour your favorite wine
into your Goverre glass,
seal the lid,
pack in your bag,
and your wine's ready
for you to enjoy
at your next
outdoor event.
Now, the best part
about Goverre ‐‐
It's not gonna spill
when Shannon knocks it.
‐Again?
‐I know. I'm sorry.
I have a habit
of knocking it over.
[ Chuckling ]
Goverre is chic.
Goverre is durable.
And did we mention
Goverre holds
17 ounces
of your favorite wine?
That's 17 ounces?
Yes, and that's
half a bottle of wine.
That's half a bottle?
‐That's half a bottle.
‐That's half a bottle of wine.
So say goodbye to using
plastic cups that spill,
and say hello
to Goverre.
Now, Sharks,
which one of you
is ready to catch
the Goverre buzz?
‐Yeah.
‐Yes!
‐Who's ready for some wine?
‐Buzz.
‐Yeah.
All right.
Herjavec: So it's a sippy cup
for wine?
‐Exactly.
‐Basically.
‐Yes.
‐It's an adult sippy cup.
What kind of wine
are we drinking, Shannon?
Well, for you, Robert,
we are having a Sauvignon Blanc.
‐Thank you.
‐Make sure to take a lid.
‐Which is Lori's?
‐Lori's is the Pinot Noir.
‐This one?
‐Turquoise. Yes.
‐Turquoise.
‐Yes, here you go.
‐Thank you.
‐Hang on.
I have to
give you a lid, Lori.
‐Yes.
‐'Cause you spill everything.
[ Chuckles ]
And for Mr. Kevin,
we have Cabernet.
For Daymond, you have
that Zinfandel. Make
sure to take a lid.
‐Ah, this is a Zinfandel?
‐Yeah.
And we saved
the best for last.
‐Mad Dog 20/20?
‐Mad Dog 20/20!
What?! [ Laughs ]
So, what type of glass
is it,
and how easy is it
to break?
Shannon: Well,
it's a white soda‐lime glass,
and it's about twice as thick
as your typical wine glass.
So it's very durable.
And then
with the silicone sleeve,
it adds that extra protection.
‐It works.
‐It works. It does.
‐Of course. Of course it does.
‐Yes.
Why ‐‐ Why would somebody
need to carry this?
So it's great for when you want
to take a glass of wine
out on your boat,
to a picnic,
to a concert
in the park
when you don't want to fuss
with a bottle and an opener.
All you do is fill your wine,
throw it in your bag,
and then you're ready
to go for your picnic.
‐I can see that.
‐Why not just make it
out of plastic?
So ‐‐
Because wine does not taste
very good out of plastic.
Of course. How can you not
know that, Robert?
When you actually
put your hand on the glass,
it transfers the heat
of the body into the wine...
Yes.
...and releases the beautiful
nectars into your nose.
Yeah! [ Laughs ]
Okay, ladies, I'm gonna give you
the benefit of the doubt
because you value this business
at $1.5 millione.
‐Yes.
‐Yes, we do.
‐Wow.
You better be selling
one ton of Goverres.
So we are, actually.
‐Well, do tell.
‐Yes. Yes.
So we've sold, this year so far,
$384,000 worth of glasses.
‐Good for you.
‐Wow.
We're on track
to sell $500,000.
Where are you selling these?
‐We sell them ‐‐
‐We sell them online.
Shannon: We're in
about 300 retail shops.
‐What type?
‐Specialty or big‐box?
Specialty.
But we did just recently
receive a purchase order
from the Container Store
for 9,000 units.
‐Oh, congratulations.
‐How much does it sell for?
It sells for $24.
Does it ‐‐ $24?
‐Yes, it does.
‐For a single glass?
‐$24 a glass?
‐For a single glass, yes.
We haven't had any pushback
on the price.
‐It's a great ‐‐
‐No?
‐Nope.
No, not really.
It's a great price point.
Wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow.
That's impressive.
For gifting.
What does it cost you
to make it?
$5.50 landed.
O'Leary: So, what's sales
gonna be this calendar year?
This calendar year, we're at
$384,000 worth of sales.
And how much
are you making on that?
Right now we're at $134,000
in net profit.
‐Good for you.
‐After you've paid yourself?
‐That's so impressive.
‐So ‐‐
‐Thank you.
‐After you've paid yourself?
We are not
paying ourselves.
Everything we ‐‐ we make
goes back into the business.
So if you paid yourselves each
as a normalized salary,
you'd be breaking even.
It's a good hobby.
Is there anything proprietary
about this?
‐Oh, yeah.
‐Why's it worth $1.5 million?
One of our most exciting
features about Goverre
is we have a really strong,
robust patent.
You have a patent?
Well, a utility patent
that's soon to be issued.
‐Issued?
‐On what?
On ‐‐ We're gonna be
the only company
that can put a drink‐through lid
on a concave glass.
When you say "concave,"
do you mean the fact that it ‐‐
So that it comes up.
‐That it has the shape.
‐Yes.
And it narrows
at the top.
It's just putting
a sippy cup kind of top on it?
So we've left the patent
broad enough
to where we can put any spout
or vessel or drinking mechanism
through the lid.
So, Regan and Shannon,
I'm a beer and vodka drinker.
You can put anything
in it.
‐Oh, I know.
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐But, uh, it's not
my space, so ‐‐
‐Okay.
‐And I can't get excited
about it, so I'm out.
‐Yeah, okay.
‐Thank you so much.
‐Thank you very much, Daymond.
‐Appreciate that.
‐Have you thought
of making a clear version
so I can see the wine through,
instead of a frosted?
‐Interesting that you say that.
‐Yes.
We ‐‐ We want to make
a more accessible version
for the bigger stores,
and that's one of the options
on the table.
Okay, listen, guys,
I like it.
I'm gonna
make you an offer.
Okay, great.
I'll give you $200,000
for 33 1/3%.
I'm assuming
you're 50‐50 partners.
‐Yes, we are.
‐We are.
I want a third.
I'm so valuable to this business
it's ridiculous.
It is.
[ Chuckles ]
Oh, God.
Okay,
that's great.
Go.
Boy, they were excited
about that, Kevin!
[ Both laugh ]
Okay.
‐Wow! Control yourself, ladies!
‐If I were you, I would take it.
I'm really ‐‐
actually ‐‐
Calm down! Calm down!
‐[ Laughs ]
‐I'm super, super excited.
I'd love to hear what
the other Sharks have to say.
Well, maybe I don't.
That's the problem.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Oh, Kevin's getting nasty.
‐So there's a lot of risk.
‐So this is your slam‐down.
‐Kevin's getting nasty.
‐Kevin!
O'Leary: I made you
a very fair offer,
given the value of Mr. Wonderful
and his great wine empire.
John: You have
the other dilemma.
If nobody else
gives you an offer...
‐I know.
‐Correct.
...then you might
have to settle.
Regan: I know.
Hey, Kevin,
would you be interested
in $200,000
for a 15% stake in our business?
‐No.
‐No?
‐They slashed you in half.
‐Here's the thing.
What ‐‐
What you guys don't realize
is you are not playing
in the big leagues yet.
Right.
The Walmarts, the Targets,
the Bed Bath & Beyond.
Herjavec: I think
it's a great product.
Thank you.
But I think what's most
impressive is the two of you.
‐Thank you.
‐You're a perfect partnership.
Let me tell you where I'm at.
‐Okay.
I'd love to do a deal on this
with Mark and Lori.
Shannon: Okay.
Oh, just to beat
the hell out of Kevin.
‐Yeah!
‐Okay.
‐Oh, that's always exciting!
‐You will sell nothing.
‐Oh, oh. I'm in.
‐Mark, would you be interested?
‐Yeah! Yeah.
‐All right.
Okay. Okay.
I'm gonna raise ‐‐
I'm gonna raise my price.
So we will squash you like
the little cockroach you are.
All right, so, Kevin,
would you excuse us?
Yes, Kevin. Leave the room.
[ Laughter ]
‐Okay, come here. Hold on.
‐[ Clears throat ]
Hold on.
We need to have a moment.
But you won't sell me,
that's the problem.
[ Chuckles ]
Ladies, they don't even know
anything about wine.
Why don't we just top
what he offered?
I don't want to sit
next to Kevin, either.
[ Laughter ]
I'm gonna go hang out
over there.
You're making a big mistake
if you don't do my deal.
I can tell you
right now.
‐Good luck.
‐Okay.
‐Okay?
‐We had a chance
to think about it.
‐Yeah.
‐Thank you for coming back.
[ Laughter ]
‐And...
‐So here's our offer.
‐Okay.
$200,000...
Mm‐hmm.
...for the same offer
as Kevin ‐‐ 33 1/3% ‐‐
and you get
three fabulous Sharks.
‐Three.
‐Okay.
‐Three Sharks in one.
[ John chuckles ]
♪♪
Amazing, right?
Amazing.
Oh, I don't know
if we're here to negotiate.
‐Together: Ohh!
‐Okay, okay!
Don't do it!
[ Laughter ]
I don't know.
Don't lose it!
Is there any way
you'd consider doing...
‐Aah!
‐...25% for three of you?
♪♪
‐Three of us?
‐You guys, it's three Sharks.
‐Yes.
‐8% apiece?
Three Sharks.
OMG.
It's funny how everybody
came to the same valuation
of your business.
That's the problem.
But, you know,
three Sharks get impatient.
♪♪
Okay.
Robert, Lori, Mark...
we'd love
to do business with you.
[ Cheering ]
[ Laughter ]
Cuban: Congratulations.
You guys are great.
‐Amazing.
‐Yay!
‐Congratulations.
‐Thank you so much!
Kevin,
don't you feel lonely?
Not at all.
Bye. [ Laughs ]
‐That was fun.
Greiner:
That was really fun. [ Laughs ]
Shannon: This is our dream ‐‐
to be on "Shark Tank,"
and we did it,
and we got a deal
with three Sharks.
‐Oh, my gosh.
‐Is this happening?
‐No.
‐No?
I don't think
this is happening.
‐[ Screams ]
‐[ Laughs ]
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is an entrepreneur who believes
he has a product
that could make the difference
between life or death.
♪♪
Aloha, Sharks.
I'm Dr. Rob Yonover
from Honolulu, Hawaii.
My company is See Rescue,
and I'm looking for $200,000
for 20%.
I'm a Ph. D. scientist
that works on volcanoes.
I surf big waves,
and I fish in rough water.
I'm always on the edge of dying.
If anything
ever happened to you,
this is what you'd look like
when you're lost at sea.
That's you.
It happens all the time ‐‐
not just on water,
but land, too.
In fact, there's three people
lost at sea every day
and seven lost hikers a day.
What?
That's why I invented
the See Rescue streamer.
See Rescue
is a visual locating device
that makes you
a large visible target,
and it works on land and water.
Kevin, can you help me demo it?
‐Sure.
‐Excellent.
Yeah,
can you get lost?
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Just walk back
the other way.
♪♪
‐Keep going.
‐Further.
‐Okay, okay, slow down.
‐Keep going.
‐That's it.
‐Wow, that's long.
These white spreader bars
are air‐filled,
and they're sealed
to the streamer
so it won't twist up or curl up.
In fact, it spins its way out
like a helix.
It has lights and reflectors
that can be seen day and night.
And it's made in the USA.
Let's lay it down
and come back in.
How heavy is it?
13 ounces and 8 ounces.
Thanks for your help.
Now, this person ‐‐
I‐I'm sorry. I don't ‐‐ I don't
see anything right there.
‐Well, that's the whole point.
‐Oh.
‐Yeah.
Your head
is the size of a coconut.
Oh, I see it, yeah.
If they can't see you,
you're gonna die, basically.
‐Yeah, of course.
‐And if you do
live through this,
you know what they say
every time?
"Why'd you fly over me
three times?"
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐Seriously.
Let's have the "after" picture.
O'Leary:
Yeah, let's see.
‐There you go.
‐Oh!
‐Wow!
‐Can you see that?
John:
That's with that.
Yonover:
This is the See Rescue streamer.
And that's as long as the one
that Kevin just rolled out.
That's the same exact one.
Well, that makes sense
to me.
‐Yeah, for sure.
‐Why wouldn't you want this?
Got it.
Every other device ‐‐
smoke, flare, sea dye ‐‐
It all runs away.
Lasts seconds or minutes.
This is the only
continuous signaling device.
This has saved
four lives already,
and I need your help...
‐Good for you.
...to save 4,000 more.
And one of the guys that I saved
thanked me.
And that was better
than any money that I've made
from this already.
You've got
two sizes there.
Right.
These are the military versions.
This is
the fighter‐pilot version.
Do you have military
that are buying these now?
These are patented,
military‐approved,
and sold all over the world.
W‐We've done $15 million
in sales.
‐Wow!
‐Whoa!
‐$15 million?
‐What?!
‐Wait a minute!
Then why are you asking
for so little?
Because here's what happened ‐‐
I licensed the technology.
This is over a 15‐year period.
My back story
is my wife got sick.
She got multiple sclerosis.
‐I'm sorry.
So she was in a wheelchair
for 19 years.
And I took care of her,
raised the kids,
and just like in big‐wave
surfing, you get drilled.
You put your head down
and paddle harder.
I paddled harder.
I led this licensing team.
And we made fantastic inroads
with the military.
So you sold the rights
to that.
The license ended.
I took it back.
It's a family business.
It was originally.
Dr. Rob, that $15 million
over what period of time?
15 years.
So, Dr. Rob,
can I see that prop?
These are
water‐soluble plastic.
Cuban: Let ‐‐
Let me see. Yeah.
I have products
for you guys.
Is this new,
or that's what
you've already been selling?
‐Yeah, we sell it all.
‐Gotcha.
‐Let me give Lori hers.
‐Thank you.
For boating, hiking ‐‐
That's the other thing.
That's all the applications.
‐It's super smart...
‐Thank you.
...'cause people do get lost.
Absolutely.
‐This is serious stuff.
‐Thank you, Dr. Rob.
You want
to do a deal, Dr. Rob,
that just supports
consumer retail sales.
I want it all.
This ‐‐ For the first time,
it's available, whole thing.
You want to start it fresh
in the Shark Tank...
‐Exactly.
‐... with a new deal
that goes after the military
and the consumer.
Correct.
So like a rebirth.
I was a big boater
for many, many years, right?
Okay.
And you're always afraid
something's gonna go wrong
on the boat and so on.
‐Absolutely.
I had
the little GPS device.
‐Sure.
‐You could put it on your body.
Well, that's a misconception
that all you need
is the electronics.
First of all, electronics fail.
This is no batteries,
chemicals, or electronics.
There's nothing
to go wrong in this.
But what do sales
look like?
They were $200,000 last year,
$250,000 this year.
Have sales dropped off
from the military
because they rely
on GPS only now?
They've dropped off
because I don't have the backing
and the funding
of a licensing group.
Herjavec:
How would you sell this?
Adventure stores,
hiking stores?
All that, but I think the
real key is for your loved ones,
really, 'cause the macho guy
doesn't think
they need anything,
yet parents or their loved ones
say,
"Yes, you definitely need this."
And, Dr. Rob,
what do you need the money for?
I want to get
the big military contracts.
In parallel,
I want to go for the mandate.
That's the key.
These should be
on every life jacket.
Every life jacket
has floatation,
but it should have visibility,
too.
So what does it cost?
$78 for the little one.
$118 for the big one.
I like the idea but only
from what you're telling me ‐‐
how many lives saved.
how much business you did.
Right.
But the real play here is,
you know,
continue with
the government,
and, uh,
I can't help you with this.
So I'm out.
Okay.
Fair enough. Thank you.
I think
it's a great idea,
but it's a really difficult
journey to start from scratch
and try to go into
the mass‐retail market.
It would require
a lot of things.
I just don't think
it's a mass‐consumer product.
I'm out.
Okay. Thank you.
It's a great product.
I think you've convinced me
for the military application.
I see
the commercial application.
I see lots of challenges
on the consumer side.
Not for me.
I'm out.
Okay.
Cuban: Dr. Rob, let me
explain something here.
Everybody's been saying
the product is great,
and I agree with them.
From an investor's
perspective...
Sure.
...th‐there's multiple things
I have to consider.
One is
how much work's involved.
The second
is how big can it be.
But something like a mandate ‐‐
If ‐‐ If it can be
argued effectively
that this should be
on every life jacket ‐‐
But that's a very
binary decision, right?
So, yeah, maybe that could
take you to $10 million,
$15 million, $20 million
in sales or more...
‐Right.
‐... but you've already
got that ability
to sell that yourself,
right?
I'm not gonna come in
and convince the military
any better
than you can.
But money can drive the team
that can build it.
But you're only asking
$200,000.
That money's only gonna go
so far.
I think
it's a great business.
I'm just not quite sure
I could scale it large enough
to give me
the return on investment.
‐I'm out.
‐Thank you.
Dr. Rob,
I look at it
in terms of what can I add
in value.
I think you nailed it
when you said it's a rebirth.
It's starting
from scratch.
It needs infrastructure.
It needs marketing.
It needs digital.
It needs social media.
Needs it all.
I like to think of my money
as gasoline.
‐Right.
‐Setting stuff on fire.
And then I participate
in the upside.
That's what
I'm good at.
That's not
the case here.
This requires a significant
more amount of work.
It's not for me.
I'm out.
Okay.
‐Thanks for your time.
‐Thanks, Dr. Rob,
and let me just say,
thank you for your knowledge
and thank you
for the lives you've saved.
It's not often we get
a vulcanologist coming in.
I wish I had more time
to pick your brain.
Any time. Give me a call.
[ Laughter ]
See you, guys.
That was disappointing.
I'm disappointed
I didn't get a deal,
but I hope at least
it gets out there
the knowledge of this existence,
and it'll save lives.
And that feels better
than money, anyway.
Narrator: Next in the tank
are entrepreneurs
hoping to create a huge brand
from a special asset.
♪♪
Hi, I'm
Amanda Latona Kuclo.
And I'm her husband and
business partner, Steve Kuclo.
And our company
is Booty Queen Apparel.
We're seeking $250,000
for 20% stake in our company.
Sharks, in case you didn't know,
butts are back.
Yes!
Now more than ever,
women are hitting the weights
with the hopes
to create a better backside.
Our company was inspired
by my wife's success
in the fitness industry.
Known for her ‐‐
‐Oh, wow!
‐Beautiful.
‐Yeah, I've seen that.
‐Hey, now.
Known for her glutes
and inspiring women
all over the world
with her amazing personality
and her signature pose.
‐Mm!
‐Wait for it.
John: Mm!
[ Laughter ]
Great pose!
Oh, yeah.
Daymond,
he's standing right there.
Introducing
Booty Queen Apparel,
a high‐quality fitness
fashion line that fuses comfort,
fit, and fashion
and focuses on,
you guessed it...
the booty.
Our brand marries strength
with glamour,
catering to the woman
that loves building her booty
and loves looking great
while doing it.
Who's ready to add
your assets to ours?
[ Laughs ]
I have to say,
I think you're the biggest man
that's ever
come in here.
‐All right.
‐That's a good thing.
Hey, I showed you
the gun show, Lori.
[ Laughter ]
Amanda: Lori, that is
the black‐and‐pink mesh.
Mr. Wonderful, of course,
green for money.
Those will look fabulous
on you.
Herjavec: Thank you.
They're heavy.
And thank you, Daymond,
and Mark.
I thought the purpose
of working out
was to get
your booty smaller.
‐No. Not ‐‐
‐Not anymore.
‐Not today.
‐See, that's what
I don't understand.
That's like '70s, '80s.
Most often,
we get various garments,
and most of them are
hiney‐compression technology.
Is this
hiney‐expansion technology?
Is there a padding?
This is very different.
This is not compression.
‐Does it enhance ‐‐
‐It leaves room for your booty
is what it is, right?
‐Yeah.
‐There you go.
Well, it okay so they're ‐‐
‐It lifts it up.
‐How does it lift it?
I ‐‐
No, it doesn't lift it.
This is just because
my butt's that awesome.
[ Laughter ]
Did you not hear the pitch?
Known for the glutes.
Did you see the cover?
No, I'm joking.
How come you don't work out
at my gym?
So this is all me.
‐Oh, the models are you?
‐Yes.
We're both champions.
I have 26 first places.
‐In fitness?
‐Wow.
‐In fitness. 10 pro wins. He ‐‐
How many ‐‐
How many covers?
Oh, at least 20
worldwide.
‐As magazines, yeah.
‐Magazines.
Were you winning
all for the booty,
or it was for everything?
Well, I stepped onstage
and became known for my glutes.
I'm very active
on social media.
For example, like,
I would always be in the gym
and I would take a picture and
I'd be like, "Hey, you know."
‐"Hey!"
‐I'd #BootyQueen.
Girls started calling me
Booty Queen.
And the next thing
you know...
So, how many
Instagram followers?
So I have
close to 700,000 followers.
‐Good for you.
‐Between all channels,
about 1 million.
Over 1 million.
Amanda, what does it do?
I still don't understand.
It's literally
an apparel line
that is basically on just the
fact that we have a following.
So there's nothing special
about it.
‐So there's ‐‐
‐There's nothing special,
but the fan base behind it
is the special.
Women will wait
in three‐hour lines
to talk to me to say
that I've changed their lives.
Herjavec:
So you're selling a brand.
Right.
The way
that your lines are cut...
Mm‐hmm.
...it seems to me like
it might lift a little bit.
‐That it...
‐Like, the booty doesn't fall.
Steve:
Most women say that.
Like,
I do a lot of the ‐‐
the back‐end stuff
with the company.
‐He's the e‐mail server.
‐I bet you do.
‐Ah, back end.
[ Laughter ]
Hey!
So when it comes to that,
you know,
a lot
of the women say,
"Oh, my God,
my butt's never looked so good."
The material ‐‐
It helps shape.
O'Leary: But, Amanda,
it's pure branding.
Amanda: Yes.
There's nothing unique
about the product,
other than
it's stylish.
‐You're selling yourself.
‐It looks good.
‐Selling ourselves ‐‐
But you want to build
this Booty Queen brand.
Amanda, I can buy
similar clothing anywhere.
This is about your brand.
Amanda:
Don't think of apparel.
Think all things booty.
‐[ Laughs ]
So for example ‐‐
I know, right?
‐Wait, that's great.
‐For example...
Greiner: Did you trademark
"all things booty"?
No.
‐You need to. Go, run fast.
‐Have you trademarked?
Have you done any trademarks
at all yet?
‐Our logo is being trademarked.
‐Your logo.
‐Do you have sales?
‐Yes, sir.
In 18 months, $375,000.
John: The pair of pants
you're wearing ‐‐
how much does it cost
to make?
And then how much
do you sell it for?
$33 to make
and $85 to sell.
And where do you sell them?
‐Online?
‐Online only.
‐Yeah, through our website.
O'Leary:
You're interesting as a deal
because you bring, you know,
a spokesperson for free.
Nobody's gonna have to pay you
a royalty.
You're the booty.
Everybody gets that.
[ Laughs ]
Look, I don't have apparel
in my portfolio yet,
and that's for a reason.
It's a brutally
competitive space.
I actually don't think you're
worth $1.25 million right now.
That's a little rich.
This one's not for me, Amanda.
I'm out.
Thank you, sir.
Guys, like Kevin, it's not
really my core competency.
I'm out.
I don't get
the whole, uh, Big Booty thing.
Obviously, it's very popular.
[ Laughter ]
So it's not even about
big booties, though.
It's about ‐‐ It also ‐‐
‐Yes, it is.
‐It's about empowerment.
It's about big booties
because that's you.
‐It is about empowering women.
‐That's your brand.
Yes.
You're adorable.
You have
a great personality.
You, too.
‐But she's talking more.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Not so much you.
Greiner: And look
how clever you are!
‐Yeah!
‐Look at that.
That's a booty with a crown.
‐Cute, right?
‐I mean, we've done all this
out of our house.
All Things Bootiful.
I think what you're doing
is obviously on trend.
You should be taking
all of that cleverness
and build a brand
and really focus on the booty.
‐That makes you unique.
‐Right.
Now you're no longer
like everybody else out there
with leggings.
You're the Booty Queen.
All Things Bootiful.
Do a line.
Do equipment,
whatever it is.
I'm not the right person
for that.
I'm out.
♪♪
Herjavec:
Amanda, I've been in this space
for the last year and a half
trying to create a brand
for various people,
working with them.
Brutally difficult.
At the end of the day,
you're really not
in the clothing business.
You're in the "you" business.
‐Right.
‐Difficult to scale that.
Not for me.
I'm out.
Thank you.
You can help us, Daymond.
That's the thing.
You can take our ideas
and implement them.
I post one video
of me wearing leggings,
doing an exercise
with the apparatus,
and I just sold an outfit,
a training program,
and a piece of equipment
from one website.
She's an influencer.
♪♪
Narrator: Four Sharks are out.
Daymond is Amanda and Steve's
last chance for a deal for their
body‐conscious clothing brand,
Booty Queen.
Amanda: You can help us,
Daymond. That's the thing.
You can take our ideas
and implement them.
I mean, there are a million
pairs of tights out there.
The only way that you can
move out ahead of the crowd
is return buyers who believe
you're an influencer,
and they keep
buying the products.
We do have a lot
of repeat customers.
And...
So it's repeat customers.
Like I said, I put these out
and I used the power
of social media and I said,
"Hey, guys, before we even
run these, before we even put
money out of our pocket,
what do you think?"
I got over 8,000 likes.
That's smart.
We pre‐sold so we weren't taking
money out of our own pocket.
And then we sold out
of our presale.
And that's happened twice.
I would normally
sit here and say,
"You don't have distribution.
Da, da, da, da, da."
But I did a deal with Sara
and Bob from Shefit last year,
a sports bra,
and they're blowing out.
I mean, they're gonna do
$5 million this year
when I just said to myself,
"There's got to be
a million sports bras
on the market."
But she has a following,
just like you.
What do you need
the money for, exactly?
We want to
increase inventory.
We'd kind of like an employee.
That would be awesome.
We're doing this
from our house.
All right, I guess
I'll give you an offer.
Um...
Look at that.
This is exciting.
I'll give you the $250,000
for 33 1/3%.
That's really good.
Would you do 25%?
Uh...
I can't.
I can't do 25%.
27.5%?
I like that you're going ‐‐
[ Laughs ]
I like that you're going up,
but I was thinking more 50%.
Oh, help me, Lord.
Phew!
Catch me, husband.
Feel free
to threaten Daymond.
I was gonna go
$250,000 for 50%.
But I will go as low as $250,000
for 33 1/3% of the company.
And that's for
All Things Booty.
We would be equal partners
on the entire brand.
And you guys say...?
Let's do it.
Got yourself a deal.
Oh, my goodness!
‐Yeah!
‐I'm so excited!
[ Screams ]
Yes!
Oh, my gosh!
‐Now pick up Daymond.
‐No, pick up Daymond.
‐Steve, pick up Daymond.
‐Pick up Daymond!
Pick up Daymond.
[ Laughter ]
‐Congrats.
‐Thank you, guys.
Oh, my gosh.
Let's go!
We've got booties!
Oh, my gosh, how cool is that?
Oh, my God.
Whoo!
We got Daymond!
Getting a deal with Daymond
is a dream come true.
It's who we came for. It's who
we had our sights set on.
Yeah, he was
the strategic partner we knew
that could really help take
the company to the next level,
scale it, and do exactly
what we want to do.
And we feel this is just
gonna be a perfect match.
Narrator: In Season 7,
we watched Erik Hopperstad
and Brian Brasch make a deal
with Kevin O'Leary
for their business
PRx Performance ‐‐
home gym equipment
that fits in small spaces.
I'll give you
the $80,000 for 20%.
‐You got a deal.
‐Let's do it.
Let's see what
they're up to now.
♪♪
O'Leary: I've always wanted to
come up to Fargo in February.
It is freezing!
Whoa!
Look, I got to see my PRx guys.
I want to see
how business is going.
[ Door closes ]
Hey, Kevin.
Welcome to Fargo.
It's real.
You actually ice‐fish out here.
You betcha.
Okay, boys, lose the rods.
I want to talk some business.
Brasch: "Shark Tank" has done
a lot for our business.
With Kevin's help, sales
have been through the roof.
This is 100%
American‐made steel.
Actually, all of this comes
from Fargo, North Dakota.
In the year leading up
to "Shark Tank,"
we only did $170,000.
Since making
our deal with Kevin,
we've done
over $1.5 million.
We're actually in the midst
of a photo shoot here.
Christmas Abbott has
1 million followers,
and she's
a professional athlete.
She came looking to us
for our equipment.
We said she's gonna be
the perfect face
for our new fitness app
PRx Fit.
O'Leary: I got to the app.
I start seeing
different exercises.
You're training me.
That's the idea?
‐Yes.
‐We bring the trainer
right to you.
PRx Fit is essentially gonna
help all of America get fit,
whether you have
equipment or not.
‐Welcome onboard.
‐Thank you.
‐This is gonna be great.
‐It is.
Guys, let's celebrate.
How about
a Fargo fish fry?
Love it.
All right.
To Fargo in the middle
of February!
What's so interesting
about this product is
not everybody has a big home,
but now they can have
a complete system because it
folds up against the wall
and takes no space.
It was a huge innovation
of the whole training market.
They ship it
all around the world,
and they're growing sales
passed $1.5 million.
This is a roaring success.
Hopperstad: We started
as two guys
that just wanted to work out
in the garage,
then a product, then a business,
then "Shark Tank."
If this isn't the American
dream, I don't know what is.
Good work.
Let's get out of here.
I'm freezing!
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is an innovative way
to keep your belongings safe.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
I'm Adam McBride.
And I'm Don Halpern.
We're from Columbus, Ohio,
and we're seeking $150,000
for a 5% equity stake
in our business
Loctote Industrial
Bag Company.
Sharks, we are changing
the way people carry
and look after their stuff.
We all carry expensive
and hard‐to‐replace items
with us every day.
You know what
I'm talking about ‐‐
cellphones, keys,
cards, cash.
But the reality is
the moment we set them down
or we turn our back on them,
too often are they stolen.
And now thieves can even
scan our credit‐card data
by simply walking past us.
Don't you just wish
your things could be safe?
Well, now they are.
Introducing the Flak Sack,
a ridiculously tough
and practical bag
made out of the most extreme
slash‐resistant textile
available anywhere.
And check this out.
With this hidden
steel‐reinforced strap,
you can lock the bag closed
and to any fixed object.
It's water‐resistant,
UV‐resistant, and of course,
it blocks RFID scanning.
All right, we've all
used them before ‐‐
the typical
drawstring backpack.
And this is how easy it is
for a thief to slash
right through it.
Greiner: Whoa.
‐And this is the ‐‐
‐No!
is the Flak Sack.
Slash at it all you like ‐‐
In, out, back, and forth.
It doesn't matter.
You're not getting in.
Sharks, we created
a product that everybody,
at some point in their life,
wishes they had.
Then we went and created
the type of business
that every investor,
at some point in their life,
wishes they own.
[ Chuckles ]
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐And with that, we came
here today to
bag some Sharks.
So who wants in?
Don, can we see them?
‐Yeah, yeah, yeah.
‐Yes.
Okay, I just want
to let you know
you're getting
box cutters, too.
They are real box cutters.
We want you guys to see
what it can actually do.
Lori, this is not a toy.
No, and please don't
try this at home.
We want you to
compare our product
to a typical
drawstring backpack.
Oh.
This one is tearing.
‐Cut.
‐Okay, I can cut that.
Now the Loctote.
Can I cut it?
‐Oh, wow.
Come on, like you mean it,
Mr. Wonderful.
So, Don, what's it made of?
Is it Kevlar?
No.
Um, that's funny.
That's the first thing
everybody says.
It's actually five times more
cut‐resistant than Kevlar.
It's actually based on
a high‐molecular‐weight
polyethylene with some
other technical fibers,
and then there's a fairly
proprietary weave.
Wouldn't somebody just
take the whole bag?
No, because you can
lock it to anything.
But how many people are
literally gonna lock it
at the airport, lock it
at a sidewalk café?
I mean, that's just
a paranoid person all around.
Well, it's not even about
locking it, right?
Greiner: Not, that's not true,
because I sell a product that
actually looks like a bracelet,
and you can open it.
You can put it around
your purse handle.
And then you put it
around the chair.
Or you put it around
the supermarket cart handle.
And it sells really well.
‐How much is this?
$179.
‐Ohh!
‐Lock him up somewhere!
How much does it
cost you to make?
The fabric is proprietary.
It was very expensive for us.
‐What is it? Mink?
‐No, it's steel mink.
What's your cost
on it, Don?
The cost on this bag
that you see today
manufactured in the U. S.
with this fabric is $75.
‐Ohh!
Which was a problem for me.
Our U. S. manufacturer
couldn't scale.
I took on a strategic partner.
We took it overseas, cut
the cost of this bag in half,
and then we started getting
a lot of requests
from mass‐market and retailers
and so forth for a product
that could fit in, say,
the largest retailer
in the world.
Walmart asked you for a version,
and was it $49 or $19.99?
They wanted to put it
on the shelf for $39.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Okay, there you go.
So it's not this fabric,
obviously.
It's not this fabric.
‐And what's your cost?
‐But what's the...?
So we got our cost
to sub $15 for that product.
I have the prototype here
if you would like to take a ‐‐
What are your sales
today, Don?
Why don't you show
the prototype?
All right, so we launched
on Kickstarter five months ago,
and our goal was to raise
$18,000 to start manufacturing.
We raised over $855,000.
How is that
freaking possible?!
Okay, okay, and there's more.
There's more.
Well, I think ‐‐ Here's my
thought ‐‐ Don, here's ‐‐
I'm looking for my ‐‐
I'm looking for our prototype
to show you the lower line.
‐I got it.
‐Well, Don, here ‐‐ here ‐‐
Here's my thought, Don.
‐Yes, please, get it.
‐Okay.
‐I'm sorry, Daymond.
‐No problem.
‐I didn't mean
to disrespect you.
‐He's getting something?
It was our ‐‐ the one
for the mass‐market bag.
So after Kickstarter, we rolled
on to Indiegogo that same day,
and within 60 days
of launching this product,
we raised over $1 million.
‐Ohh!
‐What?!
‐Fast‐forward today ‐‐
Our sales are at $1.4 million.
‐Well, hang on.
‐Including Kickstarter?
Hang on, your sales through
Indiegogo and Kickstarter ‐‐
$800,000 and then $1 million?
Or did you do $800,000 ‐‐
So it was $855,000
and then another $500,000.
So, Don, tell us a little bit
about your background.
So my background
is management consultant.
I've got an MBA
from Ohio State.
How did you find the kid?
‐I recruited ‐‐
‐He found me on
an OSU job board.
I was working a corporate
cubicle internship.
And I got a call
from this guy.
And he was like, "Hey, I'm
launching a new product.
I need some help with
my social media, marketing,
branding,
website development."
And he showed me
the product and I was ‐‐
I mean, I was blown away.
But he said he couldn't promise
a full‐time job after college.
He wouldn't
really pay me much.
I think he even told me,
like, I'd have to
clean the bathroom
or something ridiculous.
Wow.
Do you have any equity yet?
I'm working
my way towards it.
‐What?!
‐I feel like ‐‐
I didn't have any money ‐‐
I didn't have any money
to pitch in
in the beginning.
Don, what's the matter
with you?
So I'm working my way,
working my butt off.
You don't give the kid
any equity?
Don, okay, here's
the thing I can't get over.
I still don't understand
the fundamental application.
I don't think people
in a casual environment
going out to a café
are gonna lock up their bag.
Halpern: It's really ‐‐ We found
out there was two tiers.
Originally, for me, it was
all about not being stolen.
But half of our sales
were overseas.
We sold to 75 different
countries.
It's about the carrying
and the slashing.
At $175 or even $100,
you know, in the store,
the hanger appeal
is not there.
I don't necessarily
know what it is.
It's kind of hard
to translate it.
And I just didn't know
the slashing problem
was out like that.
If you're going to places
that people are slashing stuff
like that,
you don't need a bag.
You need
a Desert Eagle, right?
[ Laughter ]
Um, so I just don't
see the application.
I'm out.
Respect that.
So how are you gonna sell it?
Two ways. Um, initially,
we were gonna do it all online.
The product sells itself.
We can create rich content.
We do ridiculously
cool videos.
We slash them
with Samurai swords.
We run over them.
Yeah, that would be cool.
We hit them with axes.
That would be cool.
Look, guys, the challenge is
you haven't really defined
how you're gonna sell it.
I get that you're
gonna create content
with all the viral videos
and the fun videos you've done.
I can see that, but I don't see
how that scales at all.
What is it gonna take
to get people to your website?
'Cause that is
180 degrees different
than going to Kickstarter
or Indiegogo.
It's dependent on
your ability to create content
not over a 90‐day period
or 120‐day period,
but over a long‐term
sustained period.
That's a challenge for me,
and for those reasons, I'm out.
Don, I like kickboxing.
Having dinner
with Georges St‐Pierre,
the big UFC fighter.
I'm a big fan.
So I say to him,
"Georges, do you think I could
get in the ring and I could,
you know, scrap it up
with a couple of the guys?"
He looks at me, and he says,
"You know, Robert,
everybody has a game plan
until you get hit in the face."
You haven't been proven
by the reality
of the marketplace yet.
I'm out.
Okay, let me tell you about
getting kicked in the face
and kind of what
I'm all about
and why we're going
to be successful.
Literally
four weeks ago yesterday,
I was diagnosed with cancer ‐‐
a really nasty, nasty one.
I wasn't sure if
I was even going to be able
to make it here.
Since then,
I've had two surgeries.
The first two weeks of
getting diagnosed with cancer,
you're in a really dark place
'cause you don't know
if you're gonna see
your next birthday.
Two surgeries later,
I was on a plane
to Bentonville, Arkansas,
against the wishes of my doctor,
to sit down
and meet with Walmart ‐‐
a meeting that
isn't easy to get,
which is just pure brute
strength and driving through.
We got the meeting,
and they told us flat out,
"Here's what you need to do.
This is gonna be big.
This is gonna be huge.
Come back to me
with this product."
That is the product.
That's how quickly
we go back and we turn things.
Everything we've done,
we grind it out.
Don, you're a fighter,
and I congratulate you
on the work
that you've put into it.
You've got Lori,
and you've got ‐‐
Kevin, are you in?
I'm still listening.
Lori, what are you doing?
Well, the unique thing about
your bags is you can't slash it.
To me, the bad news is
is I'm not sure how many people
are actually slashing bags.
I like that it locks,
but you could buy a device
like mine and lock any bag.
And so there's a lot of
good news‐bad news going on,
and the worst news is
the price point at the moment.
And so, unfortunately,
for all of those reasons,
which was a lot, I'm out.
Thank you.
Don, I'm left.
Um, it's a tough one.
You got to
understand something.
After eight years
in the Shark Tank,
we've seen everything.
We see what works.
We see what doesn't work.
We look at the risk.
I don't think you should
go to Walmart.
You're kicking it out
of the park
just doing
social and digital.
And maybe you should
stay there.
The price point's
extremely high.
I'll take a flyer on it,
and it's ‐‐
I'm not interested in
negotiating with you.
I'll make you an offer.
If you don't want it, I'm okay.
Narrator: Four Sharks are out.
Don and Adam
are seeking $150,000
for 5% of their slash‐proof
locking bag company Loctote.
Kevin is their last chance
for a deal.
O'Leary: I'm not interested
in negotiating with you.
I'll make you an offer.
If you don't want it, I'm okay.
This is a classic
Mr. Wonderful royalty deal
if I ever saw one
because there's not enough
equity in this to make it
interesting for me.
I'll give you the $150,000.
I want 10%.
But I want 10 bucks a bag
until I recoup $450,000.
I'll work like hell
to get the word out.
I just want to stay digital.
So at the end of the day,
that's my offer.
I think you understand it.
Mr. Wonderful, what I would
like to counter to you with is,
first of all,
what we really need
is a line of credit for
the large purchase orders.
That means you want
to stay in retail.
Potentially,
with the low‐end product.
I don't believe
in the low‐end product, Don.
I actually don't.
My vision of
what you're doing ‐‐
And you shouldn't
do the deal with me
if we disagree on this ‐‐
Retail is a whole
different deal.
Yeah, I would not
do retail at all.
Your offer is
intriguing to me
because what I'm hearing
you say is you want
to keep your risk down,
you want your money back,
and you would like
a 10% piece of my company.
It's a product because
I want ‐‐ If there is upside,
I want schmuck insurance.
‐That's what he's saying.
Exactly,
so here's what I ‐‐
Let me repackage
schmuck insurance for you
in a different way.
So I would like to offer you
the 5%, as we said,
at $150,000,
at the $3 million valuation.
And then I would like
to give you an option
to purchase additional equity
at a $10 million valuation
to be used at any point in time,
including a liquidity event.
That's a kiss‐off
offer to me.
You take my $150,000.
You try and grow it.
I never see it back.
The royalty has to
stay in place.
You can afford it if you stay
digital and you go social.
The schmuck insurance
for me is the 10%.
Whatever happens,
if I have 10%
and I can make this thing bigger
and I still have an option
in the company,
of course I'm gonna
work for you.
So your royalty ‐‐
You're not ‐‐
He's not negotiable
on the royalty, Don.
It's not royalty.
I'm taking 10 bucks a bag
until I get $450,000 back,
and then it stops.
I appreciate that,
Mr. Wonderful.
And I certainly want you
to have your 10% upside
because I do want you
to get out of bed.
But, Don, are you willing
to pay him the $10 per bag
until he gets $450,000 ‐‐
three times
his initial investment?
That's a little bit rich,
Mr. Wonderful.
Not really.
That's ‐‐ I mean, believe me,
I'm in awe of your greed.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you.
‐And I respect it.
‐Don, what are you gonna do?
We will do the $150,000
for 10% equity.
We'll do a $10 royalty per bag
on any of the bags
until your capital
is returned at 1x,
which will be within
the first year.
‐I'll do that deal.
‐Yeah, Robert. Smart man.
I'll do that deal all day long.
‐Let's do it.
‐Do we have a deal?
‐Do it.
‐Wow!
‐Yeah, we have a deal!
‐Yeah!
Good job, Robert.
I'm sitting here and thinking,
"Why wouldn't he take that deal?
That's incredible."
‐I never send my dough out
unless I get returns ever.
All right,
good luck, guys.
‐Thank you.
‐Good luck.
‐Good luck, guys.
‐Appreciate it.
Whoo!
Yeah, baby!
Oh, my God!
I didn't see
that coming at all.
Whoa!
I really thought Robert was ‐‐
just had no interest.
No.
He laid there in the woods,
waiting, and then at the end
of the deal, he pounced.
That was incredible.
We couldn't have been happier.
We wanted Robert
from the moment
we started talking
about the show.
So that's just awesome.
Yeah.